so
demi lovato who is a v them
right i mean demi lovato is a singer who
is female but says that the demi lovato
is not female demi lovato says that demi
lovato is in fact
a
bisexual pan-gender
something
or other uh now demi lovato is doing a
new show
this is a new show that apparently is
available
on hulu or something the docu-series is
called unidentified with demi lovato
and it shows the singer along with
friend matthew scott and paranormal
investigator chris smith go to vulture
city so this was a show
whose pitch was written by a bot who had
imbibed 1 000 hours of bizarre slate
pitches and reality tv series
it's a mad lib that's a mad lib right
there the pitch for this show was
pansexual
pan-gender
frying pan
goes on journey with friend and
paranormal investigator to an abandoned
ghost town in arizona to talk with the
ghosts
so in this particular clip
demi lovato no relation to poot is seen
asking
a ghost
if had if it had seen extraterrestrials
or ufos
an electromagnetic field detector which
ghost hunters swear
by for making communication with spirits
according to news18.com was set up by
the trio for the experiment so first of
all i don't know how you get the job
professional ghost hunter how does that
work is it like bill murray and
ghostbusters and how do you demonstrate
that you have succeeded in your quest to
get rid of the ghosts
okay anyway
they set up a tool an electromagnetic
field detector for some reason ghosts
who have no physical presence
are somehow setting off electromagnetic
field detectors all right
they apparently can communicate via
electromagnetic field detector which is
weird because if they could have
physical presence that way i'm not sure
why they couldn't just turn on a light
bulb or something but in any case
the two men leave the room the ghost is
silent then the two men leave the room
and demi lovato starts asking
the ghost
who let me repeat is not there because
these are all crazy people and we're all
crazy for watching this and pretending
that this is a serious insane human
being
again let me explain demi lovato is a
gender hero
in
ish
i don't even know how he use gendered
nouns now for for demi lovato
demi lovato is one of the greatest and
most heroic humans among us
and she is completely sane she does not
have any difficulties in any way
she has she's found herself his it's his
self
they self and
demi lovato is now hunting ghosts
in a ghost town in arizona
with an electromagnetic field
detector
and
is i'm just gonna let the clip speak for
itself what happens next
i have trauma too
so i feel you
and i get it
do you like to sing carmen
oh
[Music]
you should sing something for her to me
go on and try to tear me down
i will be rising from the ground like a
skyscraper
standing ovation
um
so
what this was just to get this straight
is that the two dudes had to leave the
room because the ghost
had experienced sexual trauma
so demi lovato sang to a ghost that it
experienced sexual trauma
and then the ghost responded through the
electromagnetic field detector
apparently
demi lovato thinks positively but here's
the question how do we know
perhaps the ghost was screaming in agony
at this entire situation perhaps the
ghost demi lovato was like do you want
the men to leave and the ghost was like
yes but i also want you to leave and
demi lovato would can't communicate with
with the ghost and then demi lovato was
saying and then the ghost reacted by
screaming in pain
what if demi lovato has actually just
unleashed
this ghost and and all other ghosts into
the world to murder us all because this
is what we have come to
don't worry we are a perfectly sane and
healthy society
so this sort of thing used to be a
bizarre circus act now we put it on
peacock tv and pretend that demi lovato
is
a perfectly healthy non-crazy person
this is uh
that's that's that's the thing okay so
also
is this the way that you heal sexual
trauma also is by listening to demi
lovato songs i i mean i i i wouldn't
know i've thank god never experienced
sexual trauma but uh i'm just wondering
if you are a ghost who is raped in 1850
are you a big demi lovato fan does that
come along with the territory
like that that seems
odd
when you want a little steven foster or
something
okay instead you got this bizarre
agender human
walking in singing to you with her weird
friends who are standing outside the
room
celebrating
we are making for such a healthy society
man we don't deserve to be hit by the
sun
at all so that that's there's that okay
meanwhile in other religious news so lou
holtz who's the former coach of the
notre dame
football team he had said that joe biden
was a catholic in name only
which i mean kind of i mean joe biden
does believe in same-sex marriage
transgenderism and abortion on demand so
those are not big things in catholicism
well this is set off jim gaffigans
remember jim gaffigan
i don't even know
what is he talking about what's he
saying
so jim gaffigan used to be like the
family-friendly comedian
who it was okay to kind of mildly enjoy
well now jim gaffigan has decided to get
extremely political what's he saying
now he's getting extremely political by
announcing that lou holtz is a bad
catholic for questioning whether a
person who is pro-abortion on demand
same-sex marriage and transgenderism can
actually be a really good catholic here
is jim
gaffigan here we go
i you know just kind of unloaded it's
like the lou holtz thing it's like i
grew up like going to notre dame games
lou holtz is a child hero of mine
but the fact that
he would
be this pawn
is just like
you know what luhult
screw holds oh wow why he's using bad
language why is he
that's right i broke out my jim gaffigan
impersonation
so i i'm just gonna point out here jim
gaffigan used to have a rather wide
political audience this is a very good
way of fringing yourself away from that
audience
meanwhile louis ck doing just fine and
louis c.k was on the cancellation block
by the entire left he has a brand new
special out on his website it's super
funny and you should go check it out
if you refuse to be canceled you don't
have to be canceled but if you live in
comedy world
you feel the necessity to get extremely
political because otherwise people won't
invite you to their cocktail parties
the reason that jim gaffigan has decided
to move in this direction is because he
was apolitical and in hollywood the
assumption is if you're apolitical this
means you're a republican
right that is the assumption if you are
not overtly and wildly political the
assumption is that you are of the left
and that you are a
is that you are of the right and you are
a republican
if you refuse to go along or if you just
don't say anything at all so uh jim
gaffigan has to sound off
right now about lew
because of catholicism or something
now that is our hollywood crew they
should obviously be running the world
their principles are so much better than
yours their lives are so much better
than yours why can't we all be
open-minded and wonderful like demi
lovato
and non-judgmental in our religious
viewpoints like
like jim gaffigan
that'll make things all better
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe